so rolo what is a woman oh my goodness
well it depends on who you ask right we
need to have either an objective uh
opinion of what that is which is what uh
i mean ostensibly which is what matt
walsh was trying to achieve with this
documentary now i matt walsh if you're
watching i feel used i feel very very
used by you
because i um i actually turned down an
interview with um
dr phil at one point um he won this was
in august or september of 2020 and
really all they all his producers wanted
was for me to go on the show and sort of
like lose my mind at tommy laren at the
time because i i guess i showed up in
the algorithm somehow
and that wasn't my brand i was i didn't
want to have to have that kind of you
know back and forth because it was too
much red meat i guess at the time
however when i saw matt walsh on the dr
phil show this was back in november and
he's there with i can't i don't know the
person's name i just call him the
bearded lady and it's uh it's a
transgender man
who um
he was on there with a couple of
transgender men and i think some sort of
college professor who was
gender studied walsh the bearded lady
it'll show up i'd probably bring up my
my video on it um but
during that that conversation um it was
really this back and forth between you
know
wanting to get this empirical objective
standardized uh there you go um this
this objective definition and that's
really kind of not what matt is after in
this it's really more like red meat for
the conservative uh you know talking
point you know the red meat for uh
viewers of the daily wires what it is
and again you know that's neither here
nor there but what what gets me is that
there is sort of this ostensibly there's
this want to know
um
an objective definitive like is it is it
biological is it is it you know gender
is a social construct what is it
and it it you're just going you're just
getting the same sort of emotionalism on
the woke side the the bearded lady side
of things and then you've got uh matt
walsh on the opposite side who's really
trying to
hit it from another like emotionalist
argument which is really about moralism
and and and ethics and and uh religion
and this is just the way this is right
and wrong right versus well uh
ambiguity like deliberate ambiguity
about it and it's really an emotionalist
argument versus another emotionalist
argument and somewhere in between there
is the empirical data that says here's
what a woman actually is okay can we can
we cut the [ __ ] and please can we just
get to an empirical uh definition of
this and the reason for that is i i and
i explained this when i first watched
the the the dr phil interview um is
you're never going to get that empirical
definitive uh objective answer from the
sort of worksy left side of things
because the moment they do is the moment
their entire identity collapses
that this guy the the bearded ladies and
i'm using this as an example of of a
greater whole and all of this but once
you have a definitive answer if it's not
ambiguous if it's not subjective it's
not relative if it's not something that
you can go well you know it's all
defined by the person kind of thing once
you say no a woman is this and you're
not it
that's when the conversation dies and
that as i've said before if there is no
boogeyman no one gets paid so when matt
and matt walsh is engaging in exactly
the same
boogeyman side of things that the other
opposite side is is as well so it's just
back and forth and they both make money
off of this can you
can you imagine being as pigheaded as
matt walsh can you imagine being as woke
as the bearded lady that that's what
gets
the eyes on the screen that's what it's
the car crash in nascar nobody watches
to to see who wins the race they want to
see who crashes the car right that's the
car crash right there
and so what matt has done is uh i
thought that this was sort of uh when i
first saw the dr phil interview i
thought that it was supposed to be
something that was like just this
one-off kind of thing was asking was a
woman no it was actually it was meant to
be content
for a future documentary which is now
out which is what is a woman so what
matt has done is he's gone around the
world and he's gone to women's marches
he's gone to he's interviewed
like politicians uh congresswoman uh
congressmen uh senators whatever um uh
college professors who are teaching
gender studies uh doctors who are
performing um uh transgender like uh
from you know one sex to another
reassignment uh was it hormone blockers
we were just talking about um how biden
just uh signed off on uh the fact that
they're never they're no longer going to
to to talk about how being transgender
is a behavioral decision which is funny
because it goes entirely against what
the argument was on dr phil from the the
bearded ladies side of things gender is
a social construct there's a difference
or there's a separation between sex and
gender that is categorically false and
you can prove that it is false because
if you go and you look at so i think it
was the four laws of behavioral genetics
you look at the
look that up at some point but um
we can we can show we can prove that
gender is actually has a biological
evolutionary component to it that's how
we call it sexual dimorphism
you're never going to have that
conversation
when
the bearded lady or the feminist's uh
professor is trying to take digs at you
like who hurt you or why is this so
important to you you know is there
something wrong with you maybe you're
questioning your sexuality why are you
so insecure in your masculinity all of
those responses are emotional responses
that's emotionalism it's an attempt to
take away this empirical
want for a definitive answer and go well
the reason why you want that answer is
because there's something very wrong
with you you must be insecure that you
must have a small pp or something like
that compensating right and so
what happens is when we get to the point
where he's doing the the documentary and
he's going and having these back and
forth
it's i mean i like the premise of it but
i think the delivery and the execution
of it is really really bad simply
because all it is doing is it's it's
tapping into the fresh and fit template
of um
of sort of podcasting that
sensationalism because people will get
really upset with myron and fresh for
kicking women off the off the show we
had was brody was on here and she was
really really upset and said i think
they're closet misogynists and
everything because they won't let you
talk and they'll just kick you off the
show and just indiscriminately which is
completely false but they do that's the
template though that's the car crash
that they're like that the audience is
looking for
so they go yeah get her get her get her
get her the jerry springer right well
matt does exactly the same template in
what is a woman so what he does is he
gets these these people on uh whether
it's somebody on the street or it's the
senator or it's the uh the the gender
studies professor or whoever gets them
into the interview and then says you
know puts them on the spot there and
they can't answer the question or they
can't give a definitive answer to the
question he just sort of paints them
into this logical corner and what do
they do they rage quit they go oh i
think this interview is over and they
storm off the thing all they've done is
what myron calls frank castling right
it's kicking them off the stage except
for they do it themselves and it's the
same exact template
from the people who would have a problem
with myron and fresh doing it but it's
okay
when matt walsh does it i'm wondering if
you google what is a woman what shows up
like
is this
like this is so not anything that i ever
think what is a man was i'm just they
don't anything i'm a dude
he doesn't want an answer because
because as long as there is no answer
everybody gets paid so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]